great to be here
[Music]
for the people that don't know if you
can take
YouTube
Channel you got billions of you
know
[Music]
that the middle folder doesn't matter at
all
[Music]
seriously keep going
keep going
[Music]
what are you talking about
I think you're missing the pressure
[Music]
you're not really doing this are you
and I think it's true it is
I love mangoes too
said okay
okay now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes like
three boxes
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen do not adjust your
television it is really 2023 and for the
first time in history a president is
being indicted and will face criminal
charges this is all just such great
views such great news I was proven even
more right than I would have ever
imagined because apparently you know
there is actually igniting my father so
maybe I was wrong maybe prayer does work
like communist level of this is
dear my God
species
like communist level this
is basically communist level
communist level of great Orange
Theater Dear God
forbid Donnie boy God forbid Donnie boy
dear God
God forbid Donnie boy God forbid Donny
boy
[Music]
thank you
communist little this is
[Music]
I think that's about all we need to hear
I agree ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the live stream it's been a while but it
is so great to be back 2024's campaign
is really getting going now we have so
many different things going on and it's
just such a great opportunity to have uh
to spend with you tonight we're going to
hear from the twice indicted twice
arrested twice impeached failed former
president Donald Trump who didn't build
a wall with Mexico that Mexico would pay
for didn't have Jared Kushner solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict didn't
replace Obamacare with a big beautiful
health care plan didn't do any of those
things that's the guy we're going to
hear from tonight
that's not all that we're going to be
doing today we are going to be reviewing
some of the big happenings in the world
of political media social media of
course uh over the last uh 72 hours
Twitter suffering a very significant uh
downfall
um because of the launch of meta's
threads I am on threads I'm going to be
talking about threads I do want to just
put out there
I don't have any naivete or even
naivetea people come back and forth they
say no sir it's this way it's that way I
whatever is the pronunciation you prefer
um I don't have any of it that that meta
is Gonna Save Us right but it's gonna be
the height of political discourse it's
Twitter's really messed up and of course
eventually meta will be overrun by ads
and of course meta I'm sorry threads
will be overrun by ads and eventually
threads is going to have a lot of the
same problems we've seen elsewhere but
the point here is
Twitter is not going so well that
threads can't in 72 hours get to like 40
of the daily active users that Twitter
has that's crazy that's completely
insane that that quickly it can happen
it just reminds us about the demand that
there is for an alternative as far as
the schedule for today Trump is not
scheduled to speak till 7 30. and he's
often late but people in the room are
kind of acting like Trump's about to
come out let's listen just about
everyone we've talked to today talk
about the economy and the effects of the
economy and all right so we don't know
exactly what's going on for people
wondering what's going on here this is
an event in the state of Nevada where
Donald Trump is going to be speaking at
a volunteer recruitment event I guess
he's there to speak passionately and
spiritually about how important it is
for these people to volunteer for him I
don't know it's all pretty weird but
we're going to watch it and I assume
we're going to hear
um a lot of the same stuff that we've
heard from him many times before it's
going to be a lot of the greatest hits
which are not really they're kind of
flops to be perfectly Frank I want to
say a big thank you to Jason sickmeyer
for gifting a membership on my website
uh and everybody who's been signing up
on Twitch which puts us at 10 out of 100
for the night and I'll have more to say
about that a little bit later how long
do I expect Trump to speak anywhere from
50 minutes to an hour and 40 minutes I
mean it's it's it's sometimes it's quick
if the the room I'm guessing the reason
that all of the fans are going so
quickly is that they're having some
temperature issues in the room
Trump doesn't do well when they're
temperature issues and so that may force
him to keep it short at the same time
sometimes he goes really really really
really long in a castro-like explosion
of speech so we will see uh thanks to
Tiny sir Jen for gifting five
subscriptions on Twitch by the way
I heard from Tiny sir Jen that she
picked up a copy of the book and
actually I can't reach it let me see if
I can do this I'm just gonna lean and I
apologize for the for being rude here
oh here's I think I just pulled the neck
hammy on the here is the book and
um this is so nuts I don't know how many
people are aware of this
on a complete whim I wrote a children's
book about critical thinking
I don't know what I'm doing okay I don't
have any experience I don't know
anything about publishing I don't know
anything okay
somehow we have sold 3 100 copies of
this book
I I don't even understand what's
happening it's a best seller on Amazon
right now it's uh the Kindle version is
the number one best seller in kids
detective books the concept is like that
it's a detective book and then the paper
paperback
is the number one best seller in
children's reference and non-fiction
honestly I don't even know how we got on
those categories those aren't even the
categories that I selected like none of
this makes any sense whatsoever but 3
100 copies of this book have been sold
in Kindle or in um in in paperback we
are doing everything we can to meet
every their requests for slight
adjustments to the graphics we're going
to be making like a font change soon to
make it a little more readable we've got
all these different things are happening
the reviews are an absolute Delight
Susie finally got one for her second
grader Brandy says it's great for her
eight-year-old Brian says it's fine it's
fine three stars it's fine
um
okay
uh
uh D Ramsey says it makes a great gift
Marianna says it's a great way to
introduce folks I don't know I don't I
have a podcast I don't know anything
about writing this stuff uh oh here's a
negative review let's see this one's
good Austin says little critical
thinking required the pictures Teach as
much as the words the children reflected
in this book look as if this was written
a half century or so ago
if that was the basis I would not object
to the artwork I would hesitate to
expose children to this I don't even
know what that means it's a random
selection of topics what okay so listen
hey this person didn't like it by the
way not an authorized purchaser so who
even knows if this person bought the
book but this is the great Marketplace
of ideas you can say it's fine and give
it three stars you can say it's bad and
give it one star you can give it five
stars right now we have a beautiful 87
percent
five star rating I'll take the good with
the bad and honestly
3 100 people bought the book we have
only 36 reviews so my my I'm with total
peace and love I do want to say to
people
please review the book if you bought it
because the reviews are critical uh it's
nuts that 3 100 copies of this thing
have been sold it's also crazy to have
only 30 36 reviews so I'm not asking
anybody to buy it although by all means
go to davidpackman.com book if you want
it but um please review it if you have
purchased it that's so important and it
costs nothing to review it people are
saying 87 percent
five star is actually really good I
don't know I don't know anything about
books I mean I read them I recognize
most words in in the books I read but um
I don't know anything about this
industry I don't consider it an industry
we make almost no money off of the book
between printing costs and all of this
different stuff and then last thing
about this
people have said they'd like to see it
on Barnes and Noble we're working on
that here's the problem and this is
nothing I can control Barnes and no oh
sorry somebody wants an Obama hold on
watch this guy Pac-Man he's good that's
right that's nice Pac-Man that's Howard
Stern hold on Obama there it is
um the problem that we're having with
Barnes and Noble is they're saying that
they have an indefinite delay in
approving new Publishers like we would
be a publisher so as soon as Barnes and
Noble approves us we will get it on
Barnes and Noble that's all I can say I
can't I can't do anything else about it
um we're doing everything we can
absolutely everything we can all right
um some super chats are coming in let's
see what we've got here Sean has gifted
five YouTube subscriptions I appreciate
that puts us at 20.
Peter says the broken record repeating
all of his claims never looks forward my
Haiku to David Pacman show as I do on
The Young Turks thank you Peter
appreciate that
Jason says I bought four copies of the
book between my kids and gifts for
friends I'm bump the ebook isn't
compatible with Kindle scribe for
whatever reason Kudos and best-selling
children's other so here's the thing
I don't know if I need to do something
to make the book like when I look at the
information on the book in the in the
Amazon KDP thing I'm looking at it right
now
um
it says it's not compatible with with
some of these features
I don't know if I can turn that on I
want it to be compatible with Kindle
scribe and all of these things I'm sorry
I don't I just don't know how it works
okay but we would love to turn all those
features on if we can
uh bay photo says my copy arrived
yesterday I will review it let us know
when parents come up to you Tears in
their eyes saying sir the book is banned
in the schools okay I'm gonna it
can anybody get my book banned somewhere
please because I think it would be a
really great thing for the book for it
to be banned somewhere I don't even know
what the bands really do you know
um but if anybody can get please ban the
book Someone de sanctimonious maybe
we'll ban it I don't know I would love
to see this book banned I think it would
be useful
Matt says I'm a member I'm going to buy
some books to donate what other avenues
can we support you that is my goal to
support the program well many of the
ways you can support the program are
completely free if you're watching on
YouTube and you're not subscribed Please
Subscribe
um oh where are we at we're at a 1.79 we
could even get to 1.8 million tonight I
think the way things are going quite
frankly uh you can um what else can you
oh this is the wrong guy you can follow
me on threads we're on there share
videos I mean most of the things you can
do are free really the most direct way
to support us is to get a membership on
my website because we just pay two
percent to swipe credit cards the rest
stays with us that's the highest
anywhere that's the highest slice that
we keep of all the platforms we're on
and we do have this code indicted again
that you can use uh thanks to MOG Yugi
and Emily and punk on a bike for the
twitch Prime subscriptions here's an
interesting question do I still drink
cappuccino know in the summertime this
is really a very good question in the
morning if I have a coffee in the
morning
it's usually not so hot
so I will drink cappuccino in the
morning however in the afternoon when
it's hot I uh I have I I can't say I
developed this but I'm drinking it okay
uh you know when you go to these cafes
and you say give me a mocha and they
just pour in buckets of these chocolate
syrups that are just so sweet so so
sweet
what I've developed and this has been in
development for some time in the sense
that I just looked it up yesterday and
I'm now doing it is I have cocoa powder
if you try to dissolve the cocoa powder
directly in milk or espresso it clumps
okay and I'm not looking for clumps in
my coffee so what you do is you take
basically like a teaspoon of your cocoa
powder if you want it sweetened this is
the great thing about cocoa powder you
can control the sweetness you don't need
to be subjected to these antifa
controlled Baristas that are going to
pump you full of sugar
you can say I'm going to do a teaspoon
of cocoa powder and then a tiny bit of
sugar or a quarter teaspoon half
teaspoon whatever amount you want and
then literally just a spritz of very hot
water you mix that up you've developed
your own chocolate syrup
it's not really syrupy but it it's
Blended and then you add that to a shot
of espresso
shake it in ice add the amount of milk
that you want it's an absolutely perfect
drink absolutely perfect drink you could
have it no sugar you can sugar it up you
can do whatever you want have I tried
making affogato yeah here's the problem
I have with avogado and if we have
Italian uh viewers watching right now
although it is late in Italy here's the
problem I have with avogado you put hot
espresso on vanilla ice cream okay
unless you drink this or spoon it super
quickly you've basically got like a
melted ice cream
espresso sludge
I don't like that I don't lukewarm's not
good for me iced coffee is great and
then hot coffee is great but when you
add when when I've made avogado it just
I don't know it's just
just something about it something about
it thanks to shorty who is new member
number 24 today and also twitch
subscriber
666 which is really something I must say
um okay let's continue because that's
too much time on Coffee I'm sorry
Alex says I put honey in my iced
espresso that I've never done do I ever
go for avocado okay we just talked about
avogado not avocado can I get another
Obama where is my Obama here I just lost
oh here Obama so we have two Howard
Stern uh drops now a David Pac-Man
membership cost six bucks a month true
watch this guy Pac-Man he's good Pac-Man
he's Pac-Man man there you go I was
interviewed yesterday for one of the
side shows on uh the Howard Stern
serious radio channels it's gonna air
sometime during the summer they they
haven't told me exactly when yet so uh
we're gonna keep I'll let you know once
I hear about it I'll promote it and all
of that stuff I think it'll be really
great to be perfectly Frank I think it's
going to be good John Lieberman
interviewed me and uh it's really really
good stuff okay we're standing by for
Trump here let's look at a couple other
things that I had for us
um let's go over here
people asking am I on threads I'm on
threads at david.pakman you can follow
me there I'm I'm basically getting off
of Twitter uh slowly but surely I still
have this curated media list of stuff on
Twitter that's useful threads really
needs lists okay but I am slowly moving
off of Twitter over to thread so I would
encourage you to to follow me there I
think that that would be a really great
thing all right let's check out if we
have anything from on the ground at this
Trump event or anything that's going on
um let's see what we've got here
Christian hate preacher I think we can
skip for the time being I don't know
that we need that necessarily at this
there's enough there's enough uh hate
preachers around I don't know that we
necessarily need to be the ones giving
them attention
um
crazy stuff happened on a plane oh our
friends the good liars I talked to this
guy about the anti-drag law in Tennessee
oh this I want to listen to We are here
in Nashville Tennessee talking to people
about the the recent law that passed uh
limiting drag performances uh how do you
feel about that
stupid it's government overreach
I mean let people live their life we are
here in Nashville Tennessee talking to
people wow that's pretty interesting
that that's maybe not what you would
expect that's I mean interesting super
super interesting okay let's see what
else we have
uh Freedom caucus stuff we'll talk about
the freedom caucus thing and Marjorie
Taylor green on um Monday Katie Hobbs oh
The Conspiracy Theory Gateway pundit was
was quite literally following the
Arizona governor Katie Hobbs now I want
to make sure everybody knows when I say
the Arizona governor the reason I call
her that is because she won the election
not Carrie Lake and what I mean by she
won is she received more votes
super controversial I know she's being
stalked by this Gateway pundit and I
guess she told the guy to go f himself
let's go Jordan
[Music]
you know I have some questions about the
election in Arizona you know Maricopa
County they did these secret testing on
the machines which for the elections
procedures manual you were supposed to
oversee do additional testing
good songs
what about the signatures on the mailing
ballot affidavits
are you aware
what those look like are they looking
nothing like the signatures
of the voter
Miss Ops as Secretary of State we ever
saw
elections in Maricopa County in Arizona
do you have been an effing Russ Jordan
I'm at the gym all right I mean honestly
it makes sense to me
seems like a reasonable uh reasonable
reaction
thanks to Sean fertel for gifting a
membership at joinpakman.com let's
listen to some of these great interviews
this person I've seen for the win that's
great I was told earlier Bellagio I mean
all right maybe my boss will vimo me
some money we can do that you're live on
the air thanks greatest thing about
President Trump is what I think he's
wonderful because he actually gets it he
knows that when our uh manufacturing
left the country right we lost control
of Our Lives okay all our jobs left with
it I'm a recruiter and um I was part of
the mass exit to
um Asia and I had to find jobs for all
the people in The Shoe Factory uh that
um no longer had a job because uh Monroe
America had eight factories and they had
to downsize to three and so they hired
me to downsize she should be uh the
Commerce Secretary
management positions into sourcing and
that of you know Factory managers and so
when he came on the scene I thought he's
speaking my language he's a peace Pro
business he's speaking my language so
hopefully we can get all that turned
around now where do you live in Clark
County oh yes I do and the other reason
why I really like him is because he
understands sovereignty we need to have
closed borders and my daughter
unfortunately uh was a lawyer in
Jacksonville Florida and
um she's one of the murdered fentanyl
casualties yes and um I well you know I
mean she could have gotten some bad
drugs but I'm not sure it wasn't
deliberate because there were two people
oh oh my God it's CR listen oh my
goodness it is a tragedy to have a child
that dies of a drug addiction a drug
overdose it is a tragedy
to say that they were murdered
seems a bit much now I am not going to
understate the trauma that this woman
likely went through
but to say she was murdered by fentanyl
or fentanyl as we call
and that it was deliberate why would you
deliberately kill your customers that
that
my God I'm gonna get away from this
because this this is depressing me
thanks to asinine Frankenstein for the
twitch sub also thanks to nug Wrangler
for gifting 10 of them I really do
appreciate that and also thanks to the
great Lisa Rader for gifting a
membership at joinpakman.com you're
number 37 today a super chat from Reggie
Reggie says I got the book on Kindle and
paperback can't wait to check it out
congrats on the sales Dave it's so
awesome thank you Reggie very much
appreciate that uh it's an incredible
incredible situation that we're oh
people want to go back to this woman all
right I'll go back Liberty yes and you
know we really
what was going on
this season and I had a heads up from
Florida because I'm working with a gal
uh who's working with Nations for um
action and they are also working in the
legislature to try and stop the bad
bills in Florida
and Ron DeSantis actually passed a bad
Bill a bad gun bill because he there was
a clause in there that also allowed him
to run for office and not have to give
up the governorship when he ran right
yeah no someone had clued me in on that
a while back and I I didn't it's almost
so bizarre I didn't believe it until
they showed me but you're absolutely
right I wouldn't have believed it unless
I had heard from Debbie oh man guys I
can't do it I I we just have to stop uh
Lila Lindell with her first Super Chat
ever says David what's your opinion on
just stop oil disrupting the lgbtq
parade I Lila I don't know anything
about that unfortunately I wish I did
um and my guess is that this relates to
the question of
while we defend protesting
is the right place to protest against
oil at the lgbtq parade given that it
could be perceived as an anti-gay
protest even though it's actually an
anti-oil protest I don't know enough
about it to say for sure so I don't want
to speak about something I don't know
the details of but I think that that's
that's an interesting question thanks to
crowbars forever for the twitch Prime
subscription I really do appreciate that
let's uh let's continue with a little
bit more
of what we were looking at over on uh
over on Twitter and then we'll get back
to the um to the Trump event which is
imminently starting
uh let's see if we have anything else
even from on the ground
we may not
this is kind of a weird event
Marjorie Taylor green riding a horse I
really don't care about that I'm going
to skip that because it's so irrelevant
to me
oh no oh no no no Russell Brand
interviewing Bobby Kennedy and Cheryl
Hines
oh man I people people know that I've
been to dinner with Bobby and uh
Bobby Kennedy and Cheryl Hines and I
have a bunch of friends in common and
we've been at the same conferences a few
times I'm scared at what this is even
gonna be
so uh where are the areas where the two
of you are in plain alignment and are
there any subjects that you are
comfortable sharing that you are not in
alignment
well you know if I'm being Camden
um where we differ is Bobby is very
focused on
facts and numbers and gonna fooled me um
and I understand
feelings and people oh my God I think in
a different way so even during God the
uh pandemic I understand people being
afraid I understand people on both sides
being afraid of getting the vaccine of
not getting the vaccine people were
terrified that they weren't going to be
able to say goodbye to their
mother or father that was passing away
there were so many feelings
overwhelmingly
um this is really bad
this is really really bad Cheryl Hines
Is Awesome on curb
this is a very bad both sidesing sort of
thing
this is all bad just filling the air and
and and people's relationships and
everyone was disagreeing on
on a lot of things and a lot of it was
coming from just feelings that we were
all having does anybody know what she's
saying is she basically trying I mean
look at Bobby's face it what what is she
talking about
dear God exactly
um this is this is very bad
I think that feelings should be
addressed first
and
maybe science second
so I don't know it's so crazy because
when you hear if you didn't know
anything you would think
she's the feelings person and Bobby's
the facts person but all the all the
facts he's asserting happened to be
wrong he's like there's a hundred
studies that vaccines cause autism then
you look and it's like oh yeah most of
those don't say that and the ones that
do are very faulty and some of those
studies aren't even about vaccines and
autism it's like well that doesn't make
any sense
uh wow that's really bad
really bad
um
I I don't even know what to make of that
it's it's insane it really is I don't
even know if I should cover that on
Monday
thanks to lilika for the twitch Prime
subscription you're number 39 today I
can't tell you how much I appreciate
that I will mention to folks the most
beautiful thing you could do on this
delightful Saturday evening is grab
yourself one of these doggone
memberships joinpakman.com as you can
see above my head we have this coupon
code indicted again and when I type it
in at joinpakman.com it's criminal what
happens okay to the pricing absolutely
criminal and I'll thank everybody who
grabs one of those memberships today the
most recent person was Lisa who gifted
one and uh it's going to be I can only
imagine it's going to be a very crazy
evening when Donald Trump finally gets
to this uh completely deranged and
unhinged vet let's listen to a um
let's listen to a couple voicemails just
to see what's on people's minds and and
what's going on uh actually I don't know
that I have
I don't know that I have what I need on
voice oh let's see here hey David you
remember that absolutely ridiculous
children's book that somebody wrote
about Trump a few years ago I wonder if
once your book gained some more
popularity and uh becomes more well
known to people if they're gonna see it
in the same light that we saw that book
uh because that thing was pretty crazy
all right thanks bye people will see my
book as crazy I don't know I hope not I
hope they don't see it as crazy if the
sanctimonious bans it then we'll see
um a couple other voicemails
David
uh unfortunately I don't know any kids
but I do know a few adults that uh
think it's a joke that it's coming to
them but it's definitely not
that's genius getting the kids critical
thinking book for adults because they
don't know what the hell is going on
that's uh that's interesting all right
here's Trump
so he's actually only three minutes late
which is extraordinarily rare that
almost never happens just bizarre very
very strange
um yeah
Trump doing the thing where he points to
people in the audience which is a great
one let's see if I can read a couple of
uh super chats before Trump speaks
Giovanni says hey David just became a
U.S resident through marriage and only
took seven months it took my best friend
and his wife five years under Trump was
there a difference in policy I have no
idea on that on marriage uh no I don't
know about that David why do you think
Fox News has been obsessed with Biden
cocaine gate because they think it's
interesting to say that it was Hunter's
uh cocaine it's the absent any evidence
Bay photo must be hundreds of thousands
of people in that little conference Hall
sir crowd sizes like nobody has ever
seen yes this is actually there's a
million people at this uh of this uh
uh Event Hall
for sure nobody's ever seen anything
like it big thank you to Joe Rader Corey
Jasmine and Jack pronsky thanks for
grabbing those memberships on my great
on my website we're gonna hear from the
great orange leader Trump hopefully
he'll have some audio problems
[Music]
they lived up I used to check it every
week are they buying are they buying
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing exactly
um let's uh let's hope let's hope that
there are technical issues I believe
that antifa is in charge of the audio at
this event and you know that that can
wreak absolute havoc on a trump speech
it can just be completely completely
insane
um the red tie makes is Trump still just
standing there
[Music]
wow the song's just going on and on and
on
um a lot of people saying Trump looks
particularly Orange today uh it might
just be the lighting I don't know
um the reason he's standing there is he
comes out very early in the song
and then it you know it makes it so that
he has to stand there hinging at the
waist for a while all right let's listen
here we go
well thank you thank you very much
wow this is great have you seen what's
going on outside there are thousands of
people outside
[Applause]
there are a lot of people out there and
you know this is really just a small
gathering thank you very much I
appreciate it and I'm here for you this
is this is a gathering of just our
volunteers they go out and you knock on
those doors and the poll just came out
we're leading here by 38 points that's
not fair
and we've done well here but we're
leading uh I've never seen such
enthusiasm as we have uh this time
around we did great in 16 we actually
did much better in 2020 we got millions
more votes better and that he lost and
uh we are uh I've never seen anything
like this the level of love and the
level of enthusiasm is something that I
don't think any I'm not sure that any
political campaign has ever seen it I'm
aware that the audio is out of sync so
what I'm going to do is just refresh it
once if it's still out of sync then the
problem is in the feed okay and but this
is really just for a special group of of
you and and
and what you've done and uh again and I
think one of the reasons the enthusiasm
is so great this time even beyond what
it was last time where it was I don't
think there was anything like that but
this is substantially more because
the people we have running this country
right now are so bad
so evil they're so I mean listen
unemployment's only as low as it's been
in 50 years you know it's it's really
not going well you had something very
special very very special
almost for you can you imagine when you
think of it if time flies because now
we're talking about
primaries coming up in six and a half
months seven months we're talking about
an election that's going to take place
very quickly and we're going to win that
election in numbers
the likes of which I think nobody has
ever seen before I see it unlikely the
the level of support that we've had the
level of of absolute enthusiasm uh
nobody has ever seen this and I can go
even for the fake news because some of
the stores
some of the stories they're putting out
are just have been incredible I mean
actually incredible in terms of they're
saying the crowds we're getting are
bigger than we've ever had we had we
were in South Carolina the other day we
had almost 80 000 people
and
it was 100 degrees out and nobody wanted
to leave including me I didn't want to
leave either it was 100 degrees it was
in the afternoon and it was uh an
amazing scene and and you know to be
honest we had very fair coverage of that
and uh but this is a different kind of a
thing because this is meant for the
volunteers of the campaign for the state
of Nevada and and I just I just want to
thank you a couple of people that I have
to introduce and I want to introduce
your state party chairman Michael
McDonald has been my friend
for a long time where's Michael
this is the only unique part of the
speech where he names people in the
audience the rest of it is a speech he's
given about a hundred times not
everybody
[Applause]
a Republican National committeeman
Jim dun grafenreed where's Jim you think
that's an easy name
[Applause]
thank you very much Jim fantastic job
but we appreciate it uh Republican
National Committee woman
[Applause]
and she's a great litigator and she's
going to be litigating when they start
to cheat because they'll be cheating
like dogs there's never been anybody
that's just like these people they're
sick they are sick and you are ready
right so God you are ready
she's ready we got we got the real deal
because a lot of people say Sir will you
be able to stop the theft the cheating
sir that these people do the rigged
election and the answer is the number
one question I get number one question
and sigala we have some people all over
the country and last time I campaigned
but I assumed everything would be on the
up and up but then out on the up and up
and you go back and you see where you're
leading and we here until 10 o'clock in
the evening all of a sudden you see
these big dumps all of a sudden 302 in
the morning it's a disgrace what took
place we have we have broken borders and
we have rigged elections and you can't
have either of those two unbelievable to
have a country if you're going to have a
great country you can't have any of that
we have
a man who's been with us from the
beginning a very important man
politically assemblyman Ken Gray Ken
thank you very much appreciate it
chairman somebody that is going to be a
big factor in the success of what we're
doing uh Jesse law Jesse thank you very
much
[Applause]
and also we have many many people
friends of ours from the media that have
been really good to us that really
believe in us and they've been and
they've let it be known because they
want to save the country we have a lot
of friends here and also the Nevada
Republican Central Committee uh I want
to thank you all for being here very
special people and I don't know why but
that's actually hilarious you can buy a
lot we have a big job this is that's
been a hard State I really believe it's
a Republican state I believe
[Applause]
I believe as you know I endorse your
Governor your Governor one so that's
that's a big Advantage as opposed to the
previous governor that was not much of
an advantage I can tell you that
[Applause]
we are going to do things I think that
and this is really throughout the
country like uh nobody's ever seen
before you know they can be dishonest
and they can lie they can cheat they can
do whatever they want the one thing they
can't do is if we get massive numbers of
votes they can only go so far
so we have to slab it we have to get
massive numbers they have to come out in
numbers like they've never seen before
in order to get full screen we'll go
over to the rumble feed because people
get tired they get bored they get tired
or they didn't do a good job
as an example President Obama got far
fewer votes his second term Obama take a
look at us we got the largest number
largest increase of any president who's
ever served and they rigged the election
you know they rigged the elections just
one of those things
but the good news is they've shown how
bad they are and we can do things in
terms of crime we have to solve the
crime problem and you have it here but
some cities when you look at New York
when you look at Chicago when you look
at San Francisco what happened to San
Francisco Los Angeles so many cities all
Democrat run when you look at what's
happened we have to get involved we have
to help because the crime in this
country has gone through the roof at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
they walk in to stores now they just put
whatever they want in their cart and
they just walk out everyone's afraid to
do you saw that clip yesterday where
they're taking pictures of the people
that are stealing and stealing them
blind robbing them blind and the person
taking the pictures got fired did you
believe it
we should hire him we should find out
who he is
I was just in San Francisco last week
you know it was fine our leadership just
a short while ago real median household
income in Nevada think of this it Rose
by ten thousand nine hundred and ninety
two dollars nobody has ever had a number
like that now you're losing that you're
losing it in big ways but primarily
because of inflation because you're
getting a salary and your salary is
getting worthless it's getting just
worse it's going down at a level that
nobody's ever seen before we've never
seen levels like this where it's going
down so you think you're employed and
you think you're getting the same salary
but your salary is worth a lot less
because of what they've done and we're
going to be drilling and we're going to
be reducing energy costs
and then we're going to be selling our
energy to Europe and other places and
we're going to be reducing our debt and
reducing taxes you know you got the
largest tax decrease or largest tax cut
in the history of our country larger
than the Reagan cuts to the largest ever
we're going to be reducing taxes still
further and we're going to be paying off
that we're all set to start and then we
now of course that's you're not going to
reduce taxes and pay off debt remember
the deficit exploded under Trump also
the tax decrease was relatively modest
unless you were extraordinarily wealthy
China
although China tried to blame Italy
Spain France they were trying to blame
everybody but ultimately I said where it
came from it came from the Wuhan labs
and I said that right at the beginning
see there's a hat over there I love the
person who says Trump was right about
everything actually
you're pretty close you're pretty close
but it came right out of one but think
of that 10 992 dollars that's what you
did and yearly and nobody has ever done
that's never been done in our country
before now you're losing like amounts
because of what they've done with
inflation so we're going to get energy
we're going to pay off debt we're going
to reduce taxes we're going to then
lower interest rates because interest
rates are way too high people can
anybody looking for a house because you
might as well stop does anybody know how
the president lowers interest rates
anybody know in the chat need to do it
because they think they have to kill
inflation but you can kill inflation in
other ways also you don't have to kill
the people who are already being
destroyed telepathically by what's
taking place because we have
look we have a corrupt incompetent
leader in Biden everyone knows he's not
I wouldn't have said this three weeks
ago I wouldn't have said it I was
actually very kind to him I was very
kind to him but now we can't be kind
anymore because the gloves are off
the jar has been opened the jar
he's taken millions of dollars from
other countries like China he's totally
compromised he's taken millions and
millions of dollars from other countries
and in history there's never been never
been a scandal like this but the fake
news doesn't want to report it there's
never been done in history anything like
it 10 million two hundred thousand
dollars from China millions and millions
of dollars from Ukraine these are
compromised people these are unproven
allegations for which there is no
evidence and they're using the
weaponization of the doj or I call it
the department of Injustice uh the FBI
Etc now a judge a brilliant judge highly
respected yesterday came out with the
same top judge and a decision that the
government cannot go to the social media
because what they did was cheat okay
what they did was cheap and they cheated
on the election remember that Trump's
Administration did the same thing the
stuff that they're talking about Trump's
Administration did they would ask social
media to remove information to censor he
wanted Chrissy Chrissy Teigen Chrissy
Teigen to be banned after she insulted
Trump on social media incredible
Patriots they went around on tape
hundreds of thousands of votes stuffing
The Ballot Box the courts are afraid to
look everybody's afraid to talk the only
thing the Democrats are great at is
disinformation right as an example they
go after me they indict me but they say
they really want to run against Trump
they don't want to run against him I did
everything right and they indicted me a
lot and
oh
and we had
speaking of Falls we had some polls just
come out we're leading in Texas by 50
points against the sanctimonious I call
them
I call them to sanctimonious because he
was dead politically he was gone he was
at nothing he campaigned horribly he
came out he begged me for an endorsement
he did a little bit of work on the
impeachment hoax number one and
impeachment hoax number two did a little
work like uh he was one of 200 people
every Congressman virtually every
politician we got a unanimous vote think
of it in the Republican party because
it's hard because we have guys like
Romney and some other people in the
Republicans super tough
but in the house we got a unanimous vote
I think it was 196 or 197 to nothing
that doesn't happen and what happened
here was incredible the loyalty and the
unity and everything else but we uh he
was one of the people and he went out
and on occasion you see him on
television talking now he did it for
himself as well as for me but we had
hundreds of people doing it he came to
see me and he wanted to know could I
support him and could I endorse him I
said listen Ron you're so dead that if
Abraham Lincoln and George Washington
came back from the dead
and if they put their hands and hearts
together as
as prayed for of the pastor made a
beautiful prayer just before we came up
and I appreciate that but the president
could have prayed I think nothing is
going to say Ron you are gone
and he said if you endorse me he said if
you endorse me in the State of Florida
which we love we all love Florida and
remember Florida is easier than other
places you have the ocean and you have
the sun there's something about that
that works but uh you have the sun too
but you don't have the ocean I could say
I definitely don't have the ocean
maybe someday you'll have the ocean you
never know
kind of scary it's a long time away
right now hopefully but he said if you
endorse me when I say look you know what
you're in big trouble
you haven't run a great campaign but I'm
going to endorse you he became like that
same day became like a rocket ship and
the other guy had like a 40-point lead
had tremendous lead he was it was he
couldn't have been beaten he was already
measuring for carpets and for drapes
in the governor's mansion
and uh Ron won and then we got him past
the man Gillum he was running he was
going to be the next president of the
United States he was a good-looking guy
running couldn't be stopped Ron said I
can't beat him I don't think I can beat
him I said well you said that about the
primary two and you won said look uh
let's give it a shot we did I think two
or three rallies I think three right big
big rallies thousands and thousands and
thousands of people and they came out I
said you know you're going to win and he
ended up winning and then about three
years later they said to him will you
run against the president and he said I
have no comment on that
I said he has no comment that means he's
running
I said that son of a is running I
got him elected
so I don't I'm not a big fan of his and
he's highly overrated he's highly
overrated remember he's the one that
wanted to cut Social Security he's the
one that wanted to raise the minimum age
that he voted on this this isn't just
and the one thing you have to remember
when a politician comes out with an
initial plan and then they go into a
corner because they're getting killed
because he's getting killed he's like
he's his thing is going well he also has
no personality that helps right
you know the truth is that he's
basically flat like this is the actual
polling so when Trump got arrested he
got a little bit of a spike I know
that's really crazy but this is the
United States so crazy things happen and
then DeSantis dropped but they've
basically been flat like Trump's been
between 52 and 54 and DeSantis between
20 and 22. it's that's he's it's
basically flat I mean DeSantis I don't
see it having a path to this whole thing
but it's not true what Trump's saying
so if anybody doesn't mind losing your
social security or losing your Medicare
I suggest immediately go out and vote
for this guy but they always come back
to that position just remember that they
will go for a campaign for an election
they'll say something but they always go
back to the position uh his record on
covid was more of a public relations
stunt he closed up the state he closed
up the beaches closed up everything now
if you listen to him he didn't close but
he did but enough of that let me just
say we're we're leading by so much
the big battle is going to be we got to
beat the Democrats because they start
off with an automatic number of votes
including in your state we did
phenomenally here last time and
phenomenally in 2016 right but we have
to if we stop the cheating
we are going to win
I'm not even worried about the votes I
tell people I say I'm not worried about
the bus you know they come up sir I
would like to support you I said I don't
need any support I don't want any help
during the campaign
because I want your help during the
election they used to call it election
day now they call it election period
because some of these damn elections are
going for 62 days
where they have the balance piled up in
corners and you say what happened to the
ballots that were in that corner oh sir
we moved them to a different look that
claim has been debunked including even
courts determining there was no evidence
for that hey voting paper ballots and
voter ID right
same day voting
and remember Trump voted early and by
mail
and when we do that you know France
actually uh
I get them to do things for us with
phone calls but France had their
election recently they're 37 million
votes at 10 o'clock it was over at 11
o'clock everything was counted they had
paper ballots all paper ballots with
voter ID and they had a winner and they
had a loser and everybody went home and
now they're already campaigning for the
next election and that's the way we
should be how about this they used
machines for Speed some of these
elections go weeks and weeks and weeks
they don't know you take a look at some
of the states like here you take a look
at some of the states where we think
we're going to have a number within two
weeks Pennsylvania we're going to have a
number within two weeks you know I see a
lot of people in the chat saying France
is a much smaller country and of course
that's true but there's another
difference the US is 50 different states
across many time zones each state
running its own election different rules
etc etc France has one set of rules and
it it's all in one time zone it's also
it's it's different in a lot of
different ways they have covet or the
equivalent of coven but they use covet
in order to cheat you have to have
ultimately we got to win the election
first and if we win the election we're
going to paper ballots we're going to
immediately voter ID and obviously
that's not true because those are
decisions that states make and they're
not going to just do what Trump says
they didn't do it in 2020. question has
been a killer it's been an absolute
killer we're going to do that we're
gonna the wall so we did I love you uh
yeah another interesting point is no
Electoral College in France so you just
tally up the votes similarly in the
United States without the Electoral
College it would have been like oh
Biden's winning by 8 million this is not
close in any way what pencil whether
there's massive dumps at 2 A.M in a
Pennsylvania toilet doesn't really
matter you couldn't talk about the the
Border because the Border was so good in
2020 so I took it off I said you know
maybe I can brag about what a good job
we did but we did a phenomenal job it
was no longer a topic of discussion we
did an even better job right just
recently except they came in and they're
letting everybody flow into our country
they're letting people coming in from
prisons jails there were some of the
worst uh worst convicts anywhere in the
world and it's this part of the speech
Trump has done many times we've fact
checked it many times it is completely
untrue different countries they're
letting their prisoners out they're
emptying up their mental institutions
emptying them out don't you think that
if Mexico or some other country was
lining up buses outside of Prisons
letting people out before their
sentences are over and driving them
directly to the to the Border don't you
think we would have proof of that by
this point if we didn't build the wall
we built hundreds of miles of wall and
after we had it all finished I said give
me a report where else because when you
build it all of a sudden sort of like
water all of a sudden water and they
said sir we could do another 200 miles
so we built it and we had it all right
so all we had to do is erect the wall
you saw that happen right they could
have done it in three weeks because when
the election didn't happen then it was
up to them and instead of doing it they
took it all away and they put it in Far
Away places where people can't get to us
and when Texas and Eric this is very
untrue those materials have been
repurposed in a number of different ways
in different states we've covered it
we've had video we've talked about it
these are all lives but the crowd there
doesn't know any better that's why
they're volunteering for Trump obviously
why would somebody want it unless they
want to destroy either they're stupid
which they're not because you can't be
stupid and cheat on elections like they
cheat or by the way how funny is it that
they're saying Trump is casting his
vision for 2024 yeah oh it's this is a
deeply spiritual vision that he's he's
lining out here I'll be back in five
guys we're going to have a country if
you take a look at Saudi Arabia we have
more than Saudi Arabia we have more than
Russia we had uh
find in Alaska many years ago
and we were going to be drilling in
Alaska the likes of which nobody we
think it's probably bigger probably
bigger and War it's called probably
bigger than Saudi Arabia probably but
right around that size but maybe bigger
and we're all set to start Reagan
couldn't get it approved Bush of course
couldn't get it approved nobody could
get it approved I got it approved
and one of the first things they did is
they ended that and they ended the
Keystone Pipeline fifty thousand jobs
but much more importantly than the jobs
and think of that the union head of the
Union the pipe Union the the union that
were all the men were 48 000 people the
head of that Union was a Democrat who
fought hard for Biden and then the first
day he did the first thing I think it
was the first movie made he ended the
Keystone Pipeline those 48 000 people
were decimated they moved their homes
they moved everything they were
decimated
we had the Keystone Pipeline ended we
had Anwar most importantly and were
think of it we would have been making so
much money for this country with the
liquid gold right under our feet your
energy bills are through the roof and
everybody's in not only the cars and now
you're forced to buy all electric cars
you know maybe you want to drive for a
little bit longer than an hour foreign
there are some people that want to drive
for a little bit more than an hour you
know it's like
I'll tell you the one business that's
great though if you I don't know if
anybody has a little loose cash but go
out and buy a tow truck business because
tow trucks are doing very well right now
because all the cars are getting stuck
all over the place let's tow them to uh
an electric charger so we can drive for
another 59 minutes before that one goes
up
and you know what you should have
electric cars but you should have you
should have all types you should have
hybrids you should have combustion you
should have whatever the hell the market
will pay for we have that now that's
what you should have but a lot of people
don't is it really the market if
gasoline is subsidized or taxed or of
course I have a friend he uh always
loved driving to Washington from a
certain State he's a congressman always
loved it and now uh but he felt an
obligation to buy an electric car even
though if you think of it the batteries
making those batteries and all of the
problem is far worse in terms of the
environment if you're a big believer
which I I'm a believer that doesn't
appear to be true clean water more so
than anybody but he said I'm going to
buy an electric car
so now you have to stop five times to
get
and the stop is longer than the drive
you know
and you know what he did he ended up
gaining a lot of weight he stopped and
he ate like a dog for an hour and a half
like a dog we're gonna Deport the
criminal illegal aliens that have come
into our country
we're going to obliterate the Deep State
we were doing a good job by firing Kobe
the entire crowd Believes In The
dipstate Deep State get rid of him
it was bad news and very early on
somebody said oh why didn't you do it I
did it right at the beginning you know
he has a long-term contract I fired
Comey that was a good one that's when we
found out about the insurance policy
just in case that she lost Hillary you
know we call her beautiful Hillary now
right we changed her name because she's
a beautiful woman we call her beautiful
her you know why because I'm using the
word crooked I don't like doing the same
word for two people we're using the word
crooked for Joe Biden because Joe Biden
is the most crooked president in the
history of our country by a factor of
hundreds dear he's a crook
former president
we're gonna end all of the things you
see and ban critical race Theory and
transgender ideology
from our schools men from our universe
we're Banning it we're Banning it what
they do ban it what they do is so
horrible and you know one of the things
that I've been talking about you have to
say before anybody we are going to end
men joining women's teams
[Music]
[Applause]
you saw the swimming records are being
obliterated oh no records have stood for
19 years they're off by about an eighth
of a second
but they're going to be broken and these
young ladies are out there swimming at
five o'clock in the morning before
school they're gonna break that record
and then a guy comes along and breaks
the record by 38 seconds
the greatest is the weightlifting though
I don't know it's like 219 pounds is the
record they had on a quarter of a pound
and a little tiny little they put like
it's a piece of dust on the side of each
and a woman's there her parents are
there her boyfriend's there they're all
watching they're gonna watch her and she
gets up and she lives at barbell that
barbell's even breaking a little bit
it's bending steel barbell
and she's up almost to the top and she's
getting ready that final push she's got
a quarter of a pound just a quarter
that's all she's a former president and
can't do it just kidding oh dead mom I
can't talk
catch up boom didn't break the record
then the guy comes up have you lifted
before no I haven't oh
you haven't lifted no no but I've always
wanted to but I'm in the competition oh
goodness and he gets over to think being
[Applause]
it is so demeaning to women it's so
horrible it's so stupid it's horrible
it's it's like you know I say it's like
April Fool's uh so many of the things
they have open borders who wants open
borders who wants to have people coming
in heaven who wants people coming in
from foreign countries who wants it who
wants to have legally who wants to have
elections think of it where millions of
votes come in you don't know where the
hell they're coming they send out
millions and millions and millions of
ballots all over the place then they
come back nobody has any idea
where they're from it's it's a rig it's
a horrible horrible thing and the
Democrats you know who you know who
knows it better than anybody the
Democrats know it and in fact Democrats
Democrats the actual voter they want to
do something I hate to pause this but
I'm getting some insane report that
Trump said he wants to deny entry to
Communists and markers
into our Kuni is is this possibly true
what this was yesterday I guess let's
listen to this oh God I gotta turn off I
gotta turn off my ad blocker was Trump
this unhinged that this is what this I
have to say I will also order our
government to deny entry to all
Communists and markets look we have
marxists okay so that's a glitch
and let's see this next one this is
crazy
oh wait that's not the one
the second one here
okay that one's a glitching
interestingly
oh here we go
government to deny entry to all
Communists and markets look we have
marxists
fascists Communists they're pouring into
our country
we are going to deny them access to our
country now the one problem
but we're going to deny the markers
access to our cunning that's something I
can get behind sir very very important
uh declaration wow
the sanctimonies voted to fund Yucca
Mountain as a Dumping Ground for nuclear
wise so to Sanctus wants to use Yuca
Yuca Mountain which effect should you
say that's not just a little area that
stuff it's all over the place what a
mess so he wants you come out and as a
Dumping Ground
he's not going to say that I don't know
how he gets out of it it's like in Iowa
we had a tremendous crowd yesterday in
Iowa this is a crowd of volunteers but
Iowa we had a tremendous crowd of people
it was great but I told them I said they
want ethanol and he was against death
and all and when he was against ethanol
he just lost Iowa but now he wants to go
back and maybe he wants to rethink
ethanol let me tell you he's not going
to do it and by the way in Iowa we're
winning by 38 points too so
but if you don't mind nuclear waste
dumped in your backyard I suggest you
vote for Rhonda sanctimonious okay
say no to I say no too look we are a
special group this is a very special
group of people that's true I really
appreciate it that uh that you're here I
wanted to I actually diverted I was
going someplace else I wanted to come
and say hello to Michael and all of the
people
and uh
and this is the most and by the way
Seagal this is the most important thing
you've ever done I tell you you have to
be able to you have to be able to stop
this
just like the success you had on that
other very big fight she had a
tremendous legal success but you have to
be able to stop it this is the most
important election
in the history of our country
and I used to say that about 2016 and I
didn't say it so much in 2020 because we
had it going well little did we realize
that everything he said was a lie he
said energy is sure we love energy well
here's the love energy he doesn't love
religion either there's nobody
who's religious Christian any form of
religion that can vote for this guy
because they are against religion you
take a look look Trump's deeply
spiritual you can tell how important his
relationship with Jesus Christ is
they are against religion they're
against so much that we all stand for so
I only say this uh this is the most
important election in the history of our
country we're going to have a country
that's going to be
greater than ever before or we're going
to have a country that's going to be a
Venezuela on steroids now Venezuela
think of that Venezuela is becoming very
rich he won't take the great oil that we
have under our feet our Liquid Gold
but he's taking the tar from Venezuela
and you know where it's refined there's
only one refinery in the whole world
that can do it it's in Houston Texas so
all that stuff is spewing into the air
and they talk about they talk about all
of the things about energy
we are now making Venezuela the few
remaining people which is mostly because
so many of them have left and they'll
never be able to go back so we're making
a dictator from Venezuela who was ready
to fold if I were there he would have
been gone by now he would have been gone
in many different ways we're making him
a very rich man very rich man we are
taking oil it's not oil it's really tar
it's very heavy very horrible and
refining it is a big problem it's more
costly to refine it than it is to sell
it but with using Venezuela because I
use Venezuela Venezuela on steroids but
I can't say that anymore because
Venezuela is becoming a very rich
country and the people that are
benefiting are the people that we've
been trying to get out for years the
dictator and uh and dictators because we
had one before now we have another one
uh my hat's off to them because they've
done a great job they've conned Joe
Biden into doing something that's
Unthinkable but think of it people have
fled Venezuela and now Venezuela is
going to be a rich country for the
people that run it
people may not know this but Trump's
Trump's background is actually in Latin
American foreign policy inexpensive and
not environmentally prohibitive thank
you that's that's true
it's just something that is so crazy all
of these things I could go through 50 of
them it's literally the opposite every
single thing we should have a border we
should have great elections we should do
this we should do that we got to have
voter ID we got to have we got to do
things
properly our country is a mess we are a
failing Nation We're a nation in Decline
we are soon if we win the election and
we have no choice if we don't win the
election this upcoming 2024 election we
are going to be a country no more I
actually think it will not it will be a
country no more that's how bad it is if
Trump did you heard it here folks if
Trump doesn't win in November of 24 the
United States will cease to exist
totally reasonable prediction country it
will be greater than ever before for a
reason we've seen how not to do it if we
did it traditionally where we took over
people would say oh they'd always be
complaining now many of those people
that would have voted Democrat are going
to be voting for us you saw that uh
apologist
we're doing great with young people we
never did great as Republicans we never
did great now we're leading with young
people by 16 we're doing great with
African-American we're leading with
we're leading with women we're leading
with as they call it Suburban Housewives
you know why Suburban Housewives they
want security they want a border they
don't want everybody being killed in the
cities and then moving out they don't
want low-income housing built right next
to their house that they're so proud of
which is their next move which they're
doing so look I just want to say this we
have a chance to make America great
again we have a chance to make America
greater than ever before I believe I
believe it's the last chance I believe
it's truly the last chance and I think
that if we don't do it I think our
country is doomed to a tremendous and
horrible failure I just want to thank
you all for volunteering and for shorts
for being with us and we love you and
we'll be back many times and we're going
to have we've got a couple of very big
rallies scheduled over the next couple
of months and we'll have 60 70 000
people at these rounds but uh I thought
it was very important for me severe over
to here and be with Michael and
everybody because I want to thank you
personally now get out there and knock
on doors and do all the things that
you're doing right I appreciate it make
America great again God bless you and
thank you Pastor very much thank you
very much
[Music]
there you go
man what a lunatic
[Music]
all right so Trump uh again a very
deeply spiritual and impassioned Trump
laying out so didactically and
articulately his vision for the United
States role in the world over the next
four years uh
am I kidding he didn't do any of that
stuff
um another pathetic speech but at least
it was short speaking from 733 East
Coast to 8 12. that's 12 plus 27 that's
only a 39 minute speech folks a
39-minute speech Trump's shortest speech
in a very long time and a welcome turn
of events really for just about
everybody who's watching this channel
that's for damn sure because these
things I mean listen you get just as
much out of 40 minutes as you do out of
an hour and 40 minutes which is this guy
doesn't know anything uh spoke for
roughly oh let's listen how about 45
minutes here in Las Vegas thanks for
joining in Brian Glenn as we're live
covering president Trump's appearance
here at this recruitment volunteer all
right well we'll see if they interview
any people in the meantime listen let's
take a few phone calls just because I
mean unless we we didn't make it to 100
website members we only got to 51. but I
want to hear from people I haven't heard
from people for for a little while so
let's do it we do calls on Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord I'm gonna get the waiting Lobby
uh going and let's see here we'll start
uh live calls July 8 23.
let's take some calls just because I I
do want to hear from people okay so if
you want to talk to me tell me what's on
your mind talk about how great the
children's book is or whatever uh you
can go to davidpackman.com Discord join
the waiting Lobby I'll let people queue
up and then we'll hear from them yeah a
lot of people commenting on the duration
of the speech
um I I don't know I guess Trump didn't
really want to be there but it's just
it's Trump's world and we're all kind of
living in it you know that's that's
really what it is if you're heading out
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
and followed on Twitch and all of that
stuff so you'll know
um when we stream again and and sort of
all those things that that go on if you
are uh on the Discord right now and you
want to talk to me you do have to
request to speak you have to request to
speak if you want to talk to me that's
important Jimmy sending a Super Chat
love the show thank you for all you do
let's go to Phil from California first
see what's on Phil's mind here in this
uh 44 after a 40-ish minute from 40-ish
minute speech from Trump fill in
California what's going on
hi David can you hear me yes I can
great a long time listener second time
caller thank you
um I actually live in rural California
and
is quite the conservative conservative
Bastion out here how about and and I am
kind of curious this uh I live up in
Northern California and what should we
do about trying to be active in our
community when our community voted for
Trump like 62 percent well the community
may have voted for Trump by 62 percent
but there's usually very very little
engagement with the local decisions that
are made so there's a great Opera
there's always a great opportunity to
make something happen to affect some
change if you get involved wherever you
can right it might be school board it
might be on some local initiative it
might be whatever it is don't be
dissuaded from getting involved at the
more local level in things that might
make a real difference to people's lives
day to day just because they voted Trump
in in the general election they may not
be paying attention to those local
elections
yeah true one of the things that I
notice is in our county is they recently
uh passed uh they want to do hand
counting for our ballots yeah now
and uh yeah I was just kind of
concerning with our local government
government going up to people like Mike
Lindell for advice for elections and
stuff well listen the upside is if
they're going to Mike Lindell you can go
to someone competent so that's the one
thing I would say
all right well thank you very much all
right Phil thank you very much we're
going to keep hearing from people let's
listen to some of these interviews
we love God we love our family we love
America and you love our president
Donald Trump God bless him too
Vietnamese American for Trump forever
forever he recognized he loves you guys
I know he did I love you too thank you
so much good seeing you all right very
very exciting stuff let's go to risto
from Finland we're taking live calls in
the Discord
davidpackman.com Discord if you want to
talk to me risto from Finland welcome uh
we are live what is it like uh 3 30 in
the morning there 5 at 2 30 in the
morning
hello yes something like that what are
you doing up so late I'm curious
um
playing some games watching your stream
all right well welcome what can I do for
you okay here in Finland we just had
Parliament elections and we have several
parties in the cabinet and Parliament so
I'm thinking
would it ever happen that you guys would
have more than two bigger
part parties well the impediment to that
is how campaigns are financed in the
United States and that we have a first
pass the post system and we don't have a
proportionally representative
parliamentary or otherwise proportional
system it certainly could happen and I
hope that it will in the United States
that we have more than just this
two-party duopoly but campaign Finance
would have to change the structure of
our elections would have to change and
our system of government quite frankly
or the House and Senate would have to be
reorganized I hope it happens risto but
I'm not holding my breath
okay thank you sir my pleasure risto
from Finland uh definitely try to get
some sleep let's go to William from Las
Vegas William from Las Vegas welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
how you doing David uh first off I want
to say thank you for publishing both
your white paper and your book I just
got my book today uh in time for our
road trip so my son is excited
I I kind of censored him I said don't
read it quite yet wait till we get in
the car and on the road right that
brings tears to my eyes Sir
cheers to my eyes too uh so let me ask
you real quick sir
um with the new threads application
coming out right now yes
um we're entering into the election
season or just about going into it right
now how do we effectively uh communicate
with young groups because I still
believe that young the youngest voters
saved our bacon in the last election how
do we still move that forward with a new
application and system weaning them from
Twitter and the madnesses that is on
Twitter we have to be on every platform
okay so I I can't do this all myself but
I hope to be setting a model
what the young people went to tick tock
tick tock blew up we are now on Tick
Tock we have over 500 million followers
we now get just as many views on Tick
Tock as we did on YouTube why well
because the young people are there and
they're watching the content we have
launched on Snapchat we now are on
threads and we're going to start posting
content there we can't seed any platform
to the right because we know what they
will do did I say 500 million I'm at 500
000 followers on tick tocks I apologize
um uh we we have to be first Movers On A
lot of these platforms and not see that
oh it's just right wing stuff going on
there we've got to put ourselves in
there
I love it I'm following you on all
platforms that I have uh to include the
Spanish speaking Channel on YouTube I
don't speak Spanish but I'm still
subscribing because I want to get that
algorithm up there so we can get your
voices out there you've read so far
what was that sir how are you liking
threads so far
I like it it seems like a lot of random
people that I don't necessarily know who
they are yeah speeds
um but I I'm I'm targeting who I'm
listening to so like you driving uh uh
uh uh Tyler Cohen uh Scott Galloway I'm
kind of targeting where I'm listening
right and I think that that'll feed my
algorithm to make more sense out of it
yeah I think that one of the great
things about threads right now is
because it's smaller I mean listen 90
million users but the political space
I'm in is still smaller on threads I
actually am seeing the comments from
everybody right now which is not a
common thing like Twitter became totally
impossible to follow because it's just
so many people are sending comments
right now if you follow me on threads
I'm actually seeing what you're posting
and what you're saying to me so for now
at least it's a whole new way to hear
from the audience which I think is great
I love it so it it makes me happy
knowing that you're reading the threads
that I'm posting or replying I'm
watching what you're posting very
closely it's actually a little
suspicious the stuff you've been posting
but we'll talk about that off air
okay sounds good thank you very much
thank you all right William from Vegas
that's a joke by the way that's just a
joke okay let's go next to is it chappy
or chippy or choppy I don't know exactly
how it should be pronounced
hey there uh it's Jeffy Jeffy okay yeah
uh so enjoying the show I've been
following it sometime already
uh I'm also from the uh from Europe uh
so it's really late here but it's a day
off so it's fine I love it um anyway so
I mean it's what Trump said especially
what he says every time isn't it
um and I was wondering because
um the stream are destined if I don't
know if you're aware of him you're
talking about Cuban American streamer
Stephen Kenneth Destiny benel Goranson
II
yes yes oh yeah I know yes I know him
um I think he's some kind of fascist I'm
not sure a fascist that's not been in
your experience I don't know I heard
different things about him anyway
um he said that uh
that Trump might split the vote for the
um
for the Republicans is that the are you
of the same opinion or do you think well
I don't know what Stephen Kenneth
Destiny benel Goranson II meant what I
what I would say is if Trump doesn't win
the nomination and runs third party or
write-in he will absolutely split the
vote did Stephen mean that as the as the
Republican nominee he might split the
vote
I think he said that the centers and
Trump are basically running the party
into the ground and if uh Trump doesn't
get
to be the nominee he will just run third
party and will steal oh the vote I hope
that happens I think in that scenario
absolutely Trump would split the vote I
just think Trump has a pretty easy path
to the nomination right now
yeah so you would say it's probably just
going to be Trump again I do think so I
do think so all right thank you what
country are you calling from out of
curiosity
uh from Germany oh Germany okay very uh
good my my sister is going to be in
Germany in a couple of days she has no
idea what's going on so that'll be
interesting
um I don't know either so that's fine
you don't know her Fair okay good I'll
let her know not to worry about you all
right all right chippy thank you very
much appreciate the call let's go next
to
um Tristan from Kansas Tristan from
Kansas welcome to the program
hey David can you hear me yes I can
hope there's not too much background
noise uh just real quick I want to
compliment your veneer I guess that's
the right word I've been uh a listener
for a while I just really appreciate how
professional you are thank you
perfectly so I appreciate it uh
also I I also want to shout out how you
always refer to vosh and Destiny by
their full names I just think that's
really funny well I don't want Destiny
could be anybody right Destiny could be
I'm not going to say who else Destiny
could be but if you just say Destiny you
would have you you can conceivably not
have any idea who that is
yeah
um anyways my um
my question for you is uh you had on an
expert recently about Ai and
who wanted their particular View and
we're gonna have someone on who has a
less uh pessimistic view of AI
good because that's I'm not gonna lie to
you the previous person you had on about
AI was a lot more optimistic and I would
go to that video and listen to it
because I have like an irrational fear
of AI because of how much it's they're
just fear-mongering about it at this
point and I understand there's a lot of
concern yeah I understand that you're
referring to Eliezer yodkowski who
basically said hey I might kill
everybody uh we're gonna have a
follow-up interview with another expert
and they'll present a different view you
know
fantastic because what I my hypothesis
what I think is going on is this is
definitely a gray area and that even the
experts are unsure what the future looks
like so the gaps are being filled with
all kinds of just basically I mean it's
open the floodgates for conspiracy
theories for Pace basically anything
where it's like it's blurred the lines
between any some of the articles I see
about AI I had to tether my algorithm to
not feed me anything related to AI
because it's constantly telling me
things that sound unbelievable it almost
sounds religious guys falling stuff
going on in the space of AI so I I think
it's good to have a different you know
the people who have the view of Eliezer
would say why would you want a more
balanced perspective if the truth is
it's going to kill us wouldn't we want
to know that but of course smart people
disagree with that
exactly exactly and as a former
conspiracy theorist it's it's very hard
for for me to uh I take it all with with
skept like a healthy skepticism I try to
read the information as it comes to me
and I try not to jump to any conclusions
I look at it for what it is what it can
be used for how it can be abused well
there's so many people who will take
that and they'll say oh it's going to
completely manipulate our reality and
it's going to merge with our
Consciousness and all this crazy Alex
Jones you know what conspiracy
theory did you believe
well I used to be like very religious
and I used to believe that AI was some
kind of I don't even want to get deep
into it because I don't want people but
it's one of those things I don't even
like thinking about it this has to do
with like Antichrist excuse my
language like it was the mark of the
beast or something
yeah like Consciousness and like AI
becoming conscious and merging with our
Consciousness and creating some kind of
hive mind it's ridiculous well
listen I would wipe us out but to assume
that's the the thing that's not
invariably going to happen seems like
maybe it's a bit bit much Tristan I
appreciate the call we're gonna do that
interview very soon
okay all right there it goes Tristan
from Kansas let's go next to Dr Andy now
Dr Andy are you a medical doctor or are
you a doctor of Education like Jill
Biden trying to trick us into thinking
you're some other kind of doctor what's
the deal with that
oh God Dr Andy hasn't even accepted my
invitation
Dr Andy please uh here's Dr Andy
hello can you hear me yes I can
say hello David I'm a first time caller
uh
and what kind of a doctor are you
oh I just dropped out of Middle School
you dropped out of medical school
yeah I'm gonna go to Art School uh next
month so in what sense are you a doctor
oh man
my family want to be wanted me to become
a doctor but you know
but you you go by Dr Andy it sounds like
yeah but you're not I just wanna
no
well I like your show though a lot I
apprecially I've been listening to your
show since since when I was like
just when I was in high school like in
the 11th or 12th grade can you hear me
why did you drop out of medical school
uh
it's a long story
what's the short version
short version is that um
is it uh honor to be a bit but I don't
know no more you wanted to be a vet
yeah but I want to be a zoologist though
but you know that veterinarians don't go
to to human medical school right you did
you were you in medical school and you
were like when do we work on dogs and
then they were like no no that's
veterinary school
uh
still I'm not interested no more I got a
question to ask you though okay
um
I'm getting the suspicion you you heard
of Robert Kennedy right Robert F Kennedy
Jr absolutely I've had dinner with him
yeah interesting
um
I'm getting the suspicion that he might
be
I don't know but that he might be
cozying up with the mega movement or
that he might be some grifter or some
charlatan what's giving you the
impression is it that all of the
hairbrained former Trump advisors say
they like them very much is that what's
giving you that idea
yeah that's what's giving me the idea of
it listen Andy I've got a bunch of
videos on this so I don't want to like
retread A Worn ground but you're
absolutely correct can I tell you a
funny Bobby Kennedy anecdote that I
think regardless of My Views about his
politics he wouldn't mind me telling you
can I tell you that
yeah you could tell me Bobby Kennedy
when I went to dinner with him did
something I've never seen anyone do
which is he took a baked potato and he
ate it with his hands like it was a
finger food he grabbed the baked potato
and he dipped it in various sauces it
was like a ranch dressing and different
things he picked it up like you would a
french fry or a chicken nugget and he
was just dipping it and I've never seen
anybody do that it was sort of like in
Seinfeld when George uses a knife and
fork on a Snickers bar or whatever it
was absolutely fascinating
that is fascinating though yeah oh all
right doctor I will let you go all right
thank you very much for the call
yeah you're welcome man all right uh
yeah an important instructive phone call
if you want to be a vet
you should learn before you should learn
before going to medical school that vets
have their own schools very very
important thing to know let's go next to
oh my goodness I meant to go to Lily
from New Hampshire but I accidentally
accidentally disconnected her let me
invite Lily back
uh I'm up I'm sorry Lily I was trying to
go to you here's Lily okay welcome Lily
from New Hampshire
hi can you hear me yes I can
oh hi sorry I'm oh yeah I'm from Boston
so I really enjoyed a socks you bought
you're um watching
I'm not watching I haven't seen a Sox
game in forever and because I don't have
the local channel anymore that had every
game I barely ever would even have the
chance to I'm sorry
no it's okay
um first of all a big fan of the show
especially seeing another Bostonian um
just um so are you gonna be covering
anything from
um the uh what's it called but on the uh
the uh the shooting and Margie Duggan
um at the high school and um for Fort
Lauderdale I know they're doing some
what's it called the parents were going
into the high school you're gonna just
couldn't cover that
uh you know I don't know the exact
incident you're talking about and I
don't over the weekend I tend not to
follow any of the news that's going on
so I'm gonna have to inform myself about
that
it was from that school shooter in
Florida at Margie Stone Douglas High
School I was just wondering oh you're
saying from years ago
yeah they just the the school resource
absolutely just got a verse of not
guilty oh I saw that yeah I don't know
that that's uh I don't know that that's
necessarily a story I would have much to
say uh on you know
yeah I was just curious because I know
you cover a lot of this anyway so yeah
big fan
um my um my brother's in the National
Guard so I just thought you've been an
interesting and also my uh was actually
an ambassador so United States
Ambassador I appreciate that what are
you you doing anything in particular
tonight Saturday night
I don't I'm not doing anything
particular
um
not anything on Saturday night no I'm
not having drinks or anything
no no no no no no
all right well Lily I really appreciate
the call thank you
thank you
there goes Lily let's go next to Queenie
we're going from Lily to Queenie Queenie
welcome to the program
uh what's on your mind today
Queenie welcome to the program I've
invited you to speak but you must accept
in order to join the discussion
Queenie you are now on the air it is
your turn to speak
Queenie you probably have the wrong
audio device selected but if you select
the right one we will all be able to
hear you
and last chance for Queenie to fix your
audio
okay let's go instead to Max from
Albuquerque Max from Albuquerque welcome
to the hey David can you hear me yes I
can
hey man I have some election related
questions for you here I just want to
get your opinion on a few different
things
um so why why are Republicans following
Trump to near certain political Dune
considering the last outcome of the last
three elections or so now here
uh most of the people that are still
supporting Trump have not actually sat
down and done the math you've done which
is okay in 2018 it didn't go so well in
2020 it didn't go so well and in 2022
Maga didn't do so well
um so they're not they're just not
thinking about it logically the way you
are quite frankly there's no there's
that and and they're basically called
followers
gotcha okay cool
um and what right now where are you at
on your percentage of chance for biting
win versus Trump I think if it's Biden
Trump even money bet I'm betting Biden
it's not a it's not like a gimme but I
would guess it's like you know 55-45
Biden's gonna come out ahead as my guess
assuming the economy is roughly the way
it is today
got you got you okay 55-45 that's
interesting all right um and also why
doesn't DeSantis in your opinion
um take a more aggressive or just run
any kind of different stance against
Trump given that he hasn't really risen
in the polls and it's not really looking
all that great for him do you think he's
holding out hope that Trump's gonna get
uh in so much legal trouble that the
Republicans suddenly turn away from him
I think that is exactly what de
sanctimonious is doing because you're
you're right he's he is criticizing
Trump but he's not criticizing him as
hardcore as he could DeSantis has 21
right now we've got the poll up on the
screen polls average of polls DeSantis
wants to be there in case Trump is so uh
uh stuck in the mud with indictments and
arrests and trials and he doesn't want
to attack Maga too much because then
they won't go to him if Trump bails or
simply can't stay in the race I think
that's the shot he's taking but donors
are not thrilled and they're starting to
pull their support I think the DeSantis
campaign May implode very soon
okay awesome thank you so much man and
one more if you would sure
um how much more of a percentage of a
chance would you give a candidate like
Tim Scott or Nikki Haley in a
hypothetical manager against Joe Biden
if they were hypothetically to be the
Republican nominee
um
and I'll tell you why it's so hard to
say their polling support is so low that
you get into the inaccuracy of small
numbers when you do a poll that says
Biden versus Haley or whatever so I I
genuinely have no idea
gotcha gotcha all right thanks so much
for the questions man love the show keep
up the good work all right Max uh you
you gave me the questions but I gave you
the answers and I'm glad to do that a
little bit of question answer confusion
there but we love it I'm told queenie's
audio is fixed Queenie welcome back
please I hope your audio is now working
this will have to be the last attempt
can you hear me now yes
hi my name is actually Christina and I
actually heard from you from my
boyfriend but um you heard from me
okay
but um so my boyfriend and I both work
at a place where
unfortunately everyone in our job Wears
Like Trump shirts 2024 and okay so
listen Queenie don't or Christina don't
tell me where you work but what industry
is this
sports bars all right fair fair okay go
on
so everyone like
I he works more in the kitchen so he
doesn't have to deal with the customers
that I deal with that's nice but I work
directly with the customers okay and
I'll get customers that'll be like yo
are you voting for Trump and I'm like do
you really want to know who I'm voting
for
or like whenever like all the um
like indictments go on they always like
make comments about how the blue people
are so stupid and that they're like
rigging the election and stuff and I
don't really have a question per se but
though I guess I do have a question and
I'm getting to it how do you like work
in a place
where you're entire I live in
Pennsylvania so it's obviously my a lot
of my state swings red yep and I live in
Westmoreland County I'll keep it at that
part Fair also a red County
how do you like not run your mouth to
someone about their
facts that they have that aren't really
facts
okay so let me so I'll give you the
answer but here's first question is your
income tip dependent
yes okay so there's a couple different
things going on here the first question
is if the most important thing while
you're at work is to just
compartmentalize that you're dealing
with lunatics and you want to get the
largest possible tip I probably would
just not really do any of the things
that you could do because if you think
it'll jeopardize your income don't do
any of this stuff okay that's the first
thing I feel for that you don't want to
all of a sudden have a problem
financially because you told some Maga
clown that Trump didn't really build a
wall or whatever you don't want to get
into that you're not going to work at
this job forever fine if you wanted to
do something that would make you feel
like you're doing something but maybe
not alienate people or jeopardize your
tips
you could do the empathetic Socratic
method of questioning where they tell
you well you know that uh you know
Biden's uh doing cocaine in the Oval
Office right did you know that you go oh
I didn't know that where'd you hear that
and they go oh it's all over it's oh but
like who told you that well I actually
saw it I don't know that I actually saw
it but you know you do the questions
right you could just open-minded Quest
that's one thing and then of course if
you really want to confront these people
you can do it but then I don't I just
don't know that it's the best thing for
your job and your income you know yeah
well I had the reason I'm asking is I
actually had like customers who looked
at me and they're like don't you think
that Donald Trump did such a great job
and that Biden's doing a horrible job I
was like do you and these people they
are we're regulars at my place so like I
already knew them I also know that they
don't ever tip you so I gave them my
opinion I said honestly I voted for Joe
Biden yep so this was going to be my
next question do these Mega people tip
you well
um not typically no I usually I usually
tell that they Trump
shirts yeah and unfortunately my my boss
is one of those Trump supporters
yeah I can't even like I'm leaving my
job because I can't deal with it well if
you're going if you're leaving maybe you
want to just go down in flames and
really destroy the place metaphorically
you know and just tell everybody what
you think here's one other thing what
about something along the lines of
um people in the chat are saying
something along the lines of I tip I
vote for who whoever tips me the most or
something along that those lines it's
you know you could try it I don't know
this is a tough situation but I think
it's a good thing that you're moving on
but yeah I'm going to another job that's
tip but I have oh that's a tip base but
I'm I have a cosmetology license so it's
not
it's just going from a restaurant to
something better I say okay fair but
that's good that's good but literally my
job though oh sorry go ahead they think
that they they don't want us claiming
our tips and I do it all the time and
they yell at me but they say they don't
want to do it because of their tax break
okay let me see if I understand what you
mean by claiming tips you're so tips
come in both cash and on credit card
receipts right
now the cash the credit card receiver
receipts are automatically claimed
yes okay and you're saying you with the
cash you rather than just putting it in
your pocket you actually claim it and
then run it through as if they were
coming in on credit cards or whatever
yes well yes and no like at the end of
the shift you just type it in how many
how much you make in cash and it
automatically takes like the taxes out
for it okay listen I'm not going to give
you any tax advice but you're very
honest I'll tell you that
yeah my job doesn't like it very much
okay fair fair
they dressed up as John fetterman for uh
Halloween and said oh he's gonna be the
loser oh boy does your does the bar you
work at serve food
yes what are the most popular items with
the Maga people
Wings and Pizza boneless wings
boneless and bone-in but they're they
definitely need some boneless wings
because they ain't got no bones in their
body have any of them pointed out that
there's really no such thing as a
boneless swing and you're talking about
part of the breast do they even care
no I I figured I figured all right
Christina well listen you've said it all
we wish you the best
thank you all right wow Illuminating
Illuminating uh vignette of the uh
conservative part of Pennsylvania
uh we're gonna that's that's very
serious stuff we're gonna have to deal
with that let's go to Henry from Florida
Henry from Florida Welcome to the David
Pacman show what's going on hey how's it
going can you hear me yes
all right so this is more of a comment
of uh something you bring up every now
and again so I saw the other day you
were talking about the sanctimonious
when he bubbles his head yep you know I
was looking at the way that he does that
while listening to what he says at the
same time and uh I get the feeling that
he does that without realizing it I
think his subconscious is causing his
body to react that way as a form of
nonverbal communication yeah because you
know as little kids we're taught that if
you don't want to do something or when
you don't agree with something or when
there's something with a negative thing
to it you would shake your head left and
right like saying no I don't want to do
that well I think that that's his
subliminal way of saying don't believe
anything that I say because I'm full of
BS so if I understand correctly Henry
your view is that when DeSantis does his
bobble head thing where it's almost like
a helium balloon that's going to lift
them off into space he's not doing it on
purpose he's also not suffering from a
parkinsonian condition or tardive
dyskinesia it's not a physiological
medical issue you think that it's a
subconscious uh commentary on what he is
saying at the time
yes exactly like don't believe me don't
believe me that's interesting that's
interesting it's certainly possible
yeah well that's all I wanted to say
I've actually been holding on to that
for a couple of weeks now I figured I'd
mention it today since uh you know it's
pretty relaxed day but I love your show
I uh tune in as much as I can I even
hook up some of my friends with so your
website subscription because I really
believe in your content so just keep up
the good work because uh you know and
David We Trust I love that and by the
way is there a bird there there was I
just heard a bird
well that's actually my phone because I
got one of my buddies at uh from work
where uh we kind of gang up on the
Republicans and all the crap that's
going on in the world oh my God shows
um we usually chat back and forth so
that's my phone telling me that he's
sending me a message oh okay I thought
you maybe had a parakeet or something
no no all right Henry from Florida thank
you for the call
yeah yeah no problem thanks for doing
what you do all right there goes Henry
let's go to Cole from Alaska uh Cole
welcome to the David Pacman show what's
on your mind today
hello
uh
can you hear me yes
hello uh I I I really like your uh show
thank you
and uh um last last night uh this is uh
I have a one
non-political question and one political
question go ahead
so
um dude
so um
last night I I I was listening to your
show and and and you said that you
didn't like uh heavy metal that's right
um
so
um what's your favorite genre of music I
don't know that I have a favorite I'm
just not a heavy metal guy and I'm not a
country guy
okay
because you know I I I love heavy metal
that's fair
um
and also
um do
do you think
have you heard of Mary patola
Mia that name rings a bell let me look
that up Mary peltola
let's see U.S represent oh she's a
congresswoman from Alaska
yeah oh wait hold on she's the one
who won the seat that Sarah Palin wanted
um
do do you think do you think uh do do
you think
do you think rank Choice voting is going
to actually
um ensure that Mary patola wins a second
term I that's so difficult to answer I
mean I think incumbency has a major
power
in general whether ranked Choice voting
in Alaska will ensure she gets reelected
I couldn't say I couldn't say I would
just be guessing
yeah because because you know Alaska
used to be like
very very red yes
um
and
in the last couple of years
um
like you know
Alaska has moved leftward yes
and and I think one of the reasons why
is because
Alaska is a very libertarian like State
that's right conservatism in Alaska is
different than conservatism and say
Mississippi coal in the interests of
time curious just to know how late does
the sun stay out where you are in Alaska
at this time of year
um
say
Maybe
I I honestly am going to give a wild
guess you don't know when the sunset is
where you live right now
it's probably midnight
okay all right well that's pretty late
yeah
but but it's actually 4 51 though
no I did I know it's not night right now
where you are but the sun is out till
midnight that's interesting okay Cole I
love it
um I thank you so much for the call
great to hear from our friends in Alaska
yeah it's it's it's nice to meet you
likewise Cole from Alaska thank you so
much for the call let's go to Denise
from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
Denise go ahead
and you've got to unmute yourself Denise
please
Denise you've self-muted please unmute
yourself so we can hear from you
oh boy
oh boy all right Denise I'm going to
move you back to the audience uh you
you've muted yourself so that's why um
that's why nobody can hear you I guess I
mean it's unfortunate but let me know
when you've uh when you fixed it up
let's go to Justin from South Carolina
Justin welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hi David can you hear me yes I can you
should do voice over Justin wow
really
um I just want to say first and foremost
I am a huge fan of you
um your content
um it's it's really intellectual and
that's what I love about you
um but yeah I'm a huge I'm a huge fan of
you
um but thank you so the pre the couple
previous person was talking about the
where she worked right yes and you know
the environment so to speak well I kind
of have a similar situation uh-oh I work
for a huge company a huge company
um that is pretty much half the United
States now this company is really
conservative a conservative company
their values are conservative
um and I
and probably the far from opposite of
that right
um whenever subjects like that come up
within the company I kind of just keep
my mouth shut
um what would be a subject like what
would be an issue that comes up like
that's related well there's well there's
a lot of
um there's a lot of people within the
company who do uh where Trump
merchandise who have Trump stickers on
their cars saying you know Trump is my
president things like that it's a really
religious company as well which I think
kind of ties into the whole kind of
conservative thing
um
but
what I have been doing is I have just
been keeping to myself so to speak and
not letting my political opinions or my
opinions of that matter kind of
leak out right so so in a way in a weird
way I'm kind of like undercover so to
speak right because if I feel like I
came out and said okay I'm not religious
right I I'm not uh I'm not for
conservativism I'm like I feel like my
job would kind of be in Jeopardy and I
would get treated different I I wouldn't
I mean I wouldn't be surprised that
sounds I'm sure you would have a sense
of that
yeah yeah and so that's you know I've
been with the company for about
three years and
things like that that's all I hear about
that's all I see but in in terms of
keeping my job and and uh I just I don't
like when somebody else gets their
political opinion or even though
political opinions should not even be
discussed in the workplace nor should
religion sure
um because I I think that's a kind of a
double-edged sword like it's an
unwinnable battle
um but
I like my I had I have two questions my
first question about this is should I
continue to
just
be undercover so to speak in terms of in
terms of my job although it does bother
me right it does bother me their their
views and their you know
um
I don't mean to cut you off but it's
basically the same answer I gave
Christina which is this really depends
on
how you think it would or wouldn't
jeopardize your job what level of
hostility in terms of the environment
you're willing to have and whether you
plan on staying this job for a long time
or or not I mean I think it's it's it's
really you're the only person who can
answer this question
yeah okay so for the sake of time I'm
just gonna jump right into my next
question sounds good um do you
in your honest opinion do you think that
the Democrats need to have a different
person so to speak in terms of their
choice for who's going to run for
president in 2024 other than Joe Biden
listen if it were up to me to draw this
up the way I want it I would look at
someone who's younger and who speaks in
a way that I think is more what we need
right now to fight this these Maga
patamians and so it would be somebody
like a Gavin Newsom I find the
conversation a bit of a moot point
because when you have a president that
is in the Oval Office
and they want to run for the re-election
and they are running they're going to be
the nominee unless they die essentially
okay and the DNC has decided they're not
going to have a real primary and I I
understand this is always the case
um Etc so yeah sure I mean I think that
obviously Joe Biden is not bringing the
Vigor and excitement that somebody
younger would but it is what it is we're
where we are you know
yeah I agree yeah well listen I want to
just say man David you
your content is amazing I I love what
you do and um
they're uh I just want to say this I I
think that you look like Jake Gyllenhaal
a little bit okay if you've ever got
that in your life I have I've gotten big
Gyllenhaal Joseph Gordon-Levitt and then
some guy from the show Glee named Mr
Shoe
all right man well I just want to say
thank you for having me on I I really
enjoy your content keep doing what
you're doing and uh you know I'll always
be an avid viewer of yours and much love
to you okay all right Justin thank you
so much for the call good luck with the
employment situation we will keep an eye
on that I have to ask is the Dr Dan that
now wants to be on is this the same Dr
Dan we already spoke to earlier who
dropped out of medical school or is this
a different doctor
Dr Dan
different doctor oh different are you
actually a doctor
I'm a medical doctor and I have a PhD
two for the professor one you're a
genuine nobody can take anything away
from you you're genuinely a medical
doctor
hold on from Down Under calling from
selfish right I love it uh what's your
specialty
uh Cardiology
yeah oh boy uh what is it 10 a.m there
at to 10 30 in the middle of Australia
well welcome to the program what can I
do for you today thank you and thank you
for your son thank you I was interested
if you've subscribed to the theory that
the Q Anon phenomena is more than just a
random collection of learners but more
the political campaign driven by Trump
the political tool and social media to
try and impact the results
I struggle to think so only because
they're they're so disorganized and
incompetent that it's hard for me to
believe that something that would only
indirectly be such a campaign for an
individual like Trump
could be so well organized and proactive
I just struggle to believe that
the conspiratory movement has made it to
Australia which
one of the reasons I'm collecting or
I've got to contact with your show is
because it's made such an impact on my
work as a doctor because my patients are
refusing vaccines they're subscribing to
the Q and I'm rubbish wait wait wait
your patients are refusing what
a good vaccination oh covet vaccinate oh
yeah yeah no that doesn't surprise me
but they do they mention the Q and on
stuff specifically
specifically so they have a bunch of
relatively
left-wing
Boomer aged
the conservative people
sometimes alternative medicine
influenced yeah um are now subscribing
to anti-vax Trope but also now
supporting Putin in the war in the
Ukraine they've gone from climate change
activism to being violent Skeptics yep
and the it's really shocking and there's
a group of guys who are doing research
to understand what's driving it and how
it's reached so far across the world
there's a guy called Daniel Morrison
an excellent essay on medium if you
Google Daniel Ed Morrison and medium is
essays a lot of research looking at the
Cambridge analytica
yep and some connections with Bannon and
the Trump campaign
I'll check that out that sounds
interesting but honestly it's not a big
shock or do you have to get that is that
a patient
no no no okay
um it's not a shock to me that this has
reached Australia because with the
Internet it's basically everywhere to
some degree
so we don't have your religious
conservative politics and we've got
compulsory voting thankfully which is
savings from the French having a major
influence but we've now got four
senators in our federal Upper House
right who are basically spouting the
same Q Anon to Parliament and
so when someone says that when a patient
says they don't want the vaccine because
of some Q Anon thing what do you say
uh it depends how much time I have but I
usually blast them for just taking
from the internet and to trust
your doctor basically if we say look if
you trust me with your life and you're
taking my medicines you let me operate
on you you've got to trust me I'm a more
reliable source of information right
your Uncle Jerry has just seen something
online that's crap and how do they tend
to react usually break it down there's
two schools something that's just so
completely down the rabbit hole that
they can't deal and they don't trust us
and they walk away and they just
genuinely think the vaccine is going to
kill them yep and I'm trying to tell
them that you're an eight-year-old guy
with heart failure if you get covered
that's going to kill you don't believe
what you see online the biggest threat
is the virus uh just banging my head
against the wall trying to work out what
the motivation is for the Q Anon guys to
be driving us so hard and the only
motivation I can come for is that
somebody's getting political gain or
monetary gain from it and that's why I'm
subscribing to this theory that it's a
[Music]
political operatives to get boats or to
activate the vote in the U.S because
it's the only thing that makes sense
what a nightmare what a night that is
crazy well listen thank you for letting
us know what's going on down there can I
ask you a Cardiology question
yeah go ahead is there a definite answer
right now on cholesterol from the
standpoint of it used to be that eating
cholesterol would raise your blood
cholesterol and then more recently it's
actually it doesn't it's carbs that get
turned into cholesterol by the body what
is the truth on diet and cholesterol
right now
and so this short version is the
majority good blood cholesterol is
driven by genetics unfortunately so if
you've got shitty genetics no matter
what you eat it's going to be lousy
right you have a marginal increment to
your cholesterol if you eat High
saturated fat diet doesn't necessarily
have to have cholesterol in it but if
you have high meat fats and dairy fats
in your diet you're more likely to have
an elevated cholesterol and then if
you're massively overweight it messes
with your lipids so if you're talking
about the average American who's eating
a high carb diet and it's 50 pounds
overweight yep that's probably what's
driving their increase in cholesterol
but you can eat your eggs it won't kill
you but if you've got a genetically high
cholesterol you should be conscious of
that and talk to your doctor about
statins because you know drugs that can
make a big difference and what about the
diet makes a marginal difference oatmeal
might reduce cholesterol and it's always
like it might it's not totally clear
what what about that
and that's it's very clear that the
effect is small so if there are a whole
bunch of products called plant sterols
naturally occurring plants and that's
why the vegans have much better
cholesterol than the rest of it
um oats and there are some products in
the stores where they enhance food
products with sterols that are naturally
occurring in oats specifically to try
and trap cholesterol in your guts so
that you poo more of it out rather than
absorbing it it's effective but it's
only marginal if you imagine the effect
that the medication has it might drop
your cholesterol by half getting a
really strict dieting sterols might
reduce your cholesterol by one tenth if
you're really Middleton about it but
it's a quality life question if it makes
you miserable
you might as well eat your eggs and
don't worry about that one week off your
life or take your medicines and live
another year the medicines have such a
big impact that if you really have a
serious cholesterol problem don't get
too hung up without the diet take your
pills
Dr Dan thank you so much really
appreciate the call no and thanks for
your shirt all right there we go uh
we'll let them get back to us I don't
even think he's really working right now
but uh great to great to hear from Dr
Dan all right let's try again with
Denise from Pittsburgh Denise please
let's hope that the technical issues
have been resolved you have unmuted
welcome to the program
oh no Denise you've unmuted which is a
great first step but we can't hear you
which probably means you have the wrong
audio device selected
oh boy
all right well
oh it looks like Denise is changing
audio device Denise are you with us
no
all right well we tried we tried Denise
we really did let's go to Janelle from
San Antonio Janelle from San Antonio
previously from I forget where you
previously were Janelle
um I'm in San Antonio I've been here for
10 years but we've oh been all over the
country oh all right I think there was
another San Antonio person who recently
moved there but it must not have been
you
oh no it wasn't me yeah well welcome to
the program
thank you my question is
who's in charge of uh how many Supreme
Court judges
we have
well it's not who's in charge it's nine
and there you have there is the ability
to increase that number
um but it is it's not a question it's
not that it's somebody's in charge and
they just go well now we've got seven or
whatever the case may be
so there's nothing we can do to increase
the amount of judges to no Joe Biden
they do that Joe Biden could do that the
laws could be changed but Joe Biden has
said isn't it's not something he wants
to do in part because it would just
create a situation where okay he raises
it to 13 and puts four justices on the
court but then then we have a Republican
and they go to 17 and put four more and
you know so he's refusing to really
consider it seriously
that's unfortunate because sir it's
it's really affecting our country it is
I know I I have to say a court I worry
about the idea of just starting to
increase increase like obviously it
would solve a major problem right now I
would prefer uh term limits for Supreme
Court Justices so that there aren't
these games where oh just hold out a
little longer if you're a conservative
justice so maybe a republican wins in 24
I want to get rid of those games so I
think that a term limit would be an
interesting thing to do uh and there's
some other reforms that could be made
short of Court packing
okay thank you San Antonio's good you
like San Antonio
oh no we are we've it's not safe in
Texas for my family anymore because of
the laws and we've been trying to leave
actually we I wanted to get out as after
the last election cycle but
um
my husband delayed things which is fine
I guess but now we were having trouble
selling our house
um we are headed to Maryland we have
family there plus it's a safe haven for
lgbtq especially trans
um my son is trans and
um we need to get out of here and
actually because of the way that the you
know they the Republicans are scaring
people about the economy and then the
interest rates are up and stuff we're
having a lot of difficulty selling our
house and we live in a
an area that's very sought after our
house is really nice and all the
neighborhoods out here because we're in
the suburbs but all the neighborhoods
around
um aren't getting men much interest
because people aren't moving to Texas as
much and a lot of people are leaving and
then yeah I've heard this from so many
people and often what's actually going
on in a lot of places is the people who
own the homes and have high two low
three High three percent uh mortgage
rates they don't want to give that up
and have to get a new mortgage at six
percent so they're like I'm just not
going to sell now you're willing to sell
but then the problem is happening on the
buy side I'm hearing this in a lot of
different places
oh yeah in other states as well yeah all
over the place oh okay yeah I thought it
was just a Texas thing and I heard that
Florida was having a lot of trouble
Florida's having trouble but it's other
kinds of trouble if you know what
Florida is up to all sorts of trouble
yeah well listen I'm sorry to hear that
and I I hope you're able to sell the
place and get to Maryland
yes thank you all right Janelle from San
Antonio and that is going to put a lid
on today's stream so great speaking to
so many different people we're going to
do it again we really are folks we're
gonna do it
um uh make sure you're following on
Twitch make sure you're subscribed on uh
on YouTube get a membership get the
children's book davidpackman.com book
kids love it from the reviews I'm
reading and I wrote most of the reviews
so obviously I would know uh all right
everybody we'll see you very soon thank
you